على
الراس الى عمان الان وهذه الصور المباشره
لهذه المظاهره في هذه الجمعه في العاصمه
الاردنيه عمان هذه المظاهره دم الدعوه لها
للخروج وبقوه في هذه الجمعه دعما لغزه
وصمودها
ابم يا ابو هيبه ويمل الثم يا ابو هيبه
يمم يا ابو هيبه وبترفع
المعنويه وبترفع المعنويه وبترفع
المعنويه وبترفع المو ويا طوفان الاقصى
اشتد يا طوفان الاقصى اشتد ويا طوفان
الاقصى
اشتد معنا من عمان مدير مكتب الجزيره حسن
الشوبكي حسن نتابع معك ما كنا نشاهده قبل
قليل في هذه الصور المباشره لهذه المظاهره
في العاصمه الاردنيه عمان الداعيه لوق في
الحرب في
[موسيقى]
غزه نعم عبد القادر يعني صور الشهيد صالح
العاروري تملا شوارع عمان
والهتافات له وللمقاومة
التي حشد لها بالالاف من قبل الملتقى
الوطني لدعم المقاومه وحمايه الوطن هو ان
اوقفوا التطبيع وادعموا المقاومه وهنالك
اعارات ايضا تقول ان الحصار جريمه امريكيه
بايد عربيه وا اضافه الى انهم يطالبون
بوقف المحرقه في غزه الحال الشارع الاردني
منذ اكثر من ثلاه اشهر ونحن ندخل يعني في
الشهر الرابع هذا الشهر الرابع لذا
العدوان على غزه والشارع ينتفض بكل
مستوياته وفي كل
المحافظات في الشمال في الجنوب في عمان
اليوم هذا هذه الحشود الكبيره التي تملى
شوارع عمان انطلقت من المسجد الحسيني من
امام المسجد الحسيني بعد صلاه الجمعه
والاعداد بصراحه عبد القادر كبيره جدا
بالالاف
والكل يدعو الى وقف التطبيع مع اسرائيل
وايجاد حل لهذه الاباده الجماعيه التي
يقوم بها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني الاعزل في غزه وفي الضفه
الغربيه ويقولون انهم يعني يدعمون فقط
المقاومه ويطالبون النظام الرسمي العربي
ان يتجاوز مربعات الادانه والبيانات الى
الوصول لمستوى اعلى يتعلق بدعم المقاومه
بشكل حقيقي حتى يتم احداث الفرق واحداث
الاستداره
المطلوبه طبعا الملتقى الوطني ل دعم
المقاومه وحمايه الوطن يعني وهنالك احزاب
مثل حزب جبه العمل الاسلامي الحركه
الاسلاميه وكذلك حزب الوحده الشعبيه وحزب
العمال يعني باضافه الى يعني
كوادرهم الجانب الشعبي حضور كبير والعنوان
الابرز كما قلت لك عبد القادر هو دعم
المقاومه وهنالك يعني انتفاضه في الشارع
الاردني بعد الاستهداف الذي تقوم به
اسرائيل لقيادات المقاومه هتف المتظاهرون
هنا في عمان عبد القادر للشهيد صالح
العاروري ولرفاقه الذين قضوا في التفجير
الذي جرى في بيروت الضاحيه الجنوبيه شكرا
لك من عمان مدير مكتب الجزيره حسن
الشوبكي